hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain an american
science fiction and fantasy movie called
colossal
the movie begins with a little girl who
is in the park with her mother
apparently the girl is looking for her
doll which has fallen around the park
after finding the doll they see a giant
monster suddenly appears and walks
through the city
25 years later a drunk woman enters an
apartment in new york city her name is
gloria and she works as an unemployed
writer unfortunately she really likes to
get drunk every day
on the other hand her boyfriend tim
looks annoyed with her drunken behavior
as she tries to explain her situation to
her boyfriend
because of this tim gets frustrated and
tells her that he has packed up her
things wanting her to get out of his
apartment
their relationship automatically ends
while she still cannot believe it
soon gloria decides to return to her
hometown in new hampshire while she is
walking alone on the streets she
accidentally meets her childhood friend
oscar he owns a nearby bar inherited by
his late father
he warmly welcomes gloria and invites
her to his bar that night there gloria
meets his other friends named joel and
garth
they are also happy to welcome her to
the bar
later oscar visits gloria's house
bringing a television into her house
which looks completely unfurnished
gloria did not tell oscar that the
reason she came back to new england was
because her ex-boyfriend kicked her out
of his apartment but she tells him that
she came back here for work reasons
on the other side oscar already knew the
real reason she came back here from
their conversation last night when she
was drunk and unconscious because of
that he offers a job at his bar which
she accepts
sadly working at the bar aggravates
glorious alcohol problem after each
shift she drinks heavily with oscar joel
and garth until morning somehow she
unintentionally sleeps on a bench near
the playground one morning at the same
time the giant monster reappears again
in seoul leaving death and destruction
in its wake
after that oscar shows gloria the
recording news about the giant monster
earlier
when she looks at the news she notices
something odd about the monster the
monster was scratching his head which is
the same thing she did earlier
she also notices something interesting
in the previous recording of the monster
it looks like the monster was carrying
something on his back
the following day she heads to the
playground around the same time the
monster starts appearing on the news at
first she raises her left hand ending
with her raising both hands she then
rushes back to her house to see the news
about the monster sure enough the
monster mimics exactly what glory did
just now she then realizes that she is
the one who caused the monster to
manifest and can remotely control it
with this discovery she reveals the
secret to oscar and his friends she also
invites them to go to the playground
together the next day exactly at 8 05 am
which is the time when the monster
starts appearing in seoul
upon their arrival gloria dances in the
playground while they watch the news
feed of the monster mimicking her
movement simultaneously oscar and his
friends are shocked about it
after a while they inform gloria that
there are helicopters launching a
missile at the monster which physically
affects her as well
she makes a punching gesture causing the
monster to lash out and destroy the
helicopter including its pilot
realizing the seriousness of the
situation she panics and collapses as
oscar walks towards her
after she wakes up she watches the news
and finds out that the fallen monster
caused serious destruction killing many
people
shortly after oscar comes to her house
and shows the newspaper that he also
manifested in seoul but as a giant robot
which seems to be talking to the monster
the two of them try to find out what
really happened before gloria believes
that everything has to do with their
past when they were kids but they still
cannot remember what happened at that
time because it happened so long ago
most importantly she tries to make
amends for the south korean people in
the media
she goes back to the playground and asks
everyone to stay away from the monster
she then writes the message on the
ground while the monster spells out an
apology in korean which oscar's friend
translated beforehand
since then she begins to avoid both the
playground and alcohol it turns out that
oscar secretly keeps his feelings for
gloria all this time but unfortunately
gloria falls in love with joel
after spending the night with joel glory
discovers a drunken oscar in the
playground he is controlling the robot
to taunt south korea fortunately gloria
manages to make him leave the playground
after a tense confrontation besides that
oscar thinks that something happened
between glory and joel causing him to be
jealous
that night he drunkenly insult scarf at
the bar as a result garth choses to
leave the bar
meanwhile oscar demands gloria for
another beer but she refuses causing him
to be angry he also threatens that he
will return to the playground
since gloria knows a drunk oscar would
mess up she immediately chases him into
the playground
long story short the two of them have a
fight again it ends with glory quitting
her job but he still forces her to work
there the following morning joel
suddenly comes to gloria's house with a
lot of furniture he says that it is a
gift from oscar who apologizes to her
a few days later gloria goes to the
nearby hotel where tim is staying after
she receives an email from him he
arrives in the town to see gloria but he
is eventually irritated and dismissive
about her life situation working as a
waiter at the bar
then they go to the bar where oscar is
already drunk after he sees gloria
coming with tim oscar provokes a
confrontation by setting off fireworks
indoors in order to scare tim before
leaving tim tells gloria that he will be
returning to new york tomorrow and asks
her to go with him
at night gloria is surprised to see
oscar somehow in her house
he goes there to prevent her from going
back to new york with tim
therefore she can remember her past
events with oscar as a kid through a
flashback it was seen that gloria and
oscar as children are on their way to
school
she brings her soul paper diorama of
soul as a school project
suddenly her diorama was blown by the
wind over playground
thus oscar helps her to take it however
he was jealous because glorious diorama
was better than his own causing him to
smash it
seeing this from afar glory becomes
angry and triggers lightning that
strikes them oscar's toy robot and her
toy reptilian monster
back in the present gloria finally
recognizes oscar's manipulative behavior
combined with destroyed photos and other
clues around his house everything arises
from his self-hatred she then calls tim
and resolves to leave town with him
knowing this oscar becomes angry with
her the two of them start fighting and
smashing furniture in the end they race
for the playground she arrives first and
attempts to fight him unluckily he is
able to incapacitate her and eventually
destroys a large portion of soul from
the playground while gloria is lying
helplessly on the ground
he also says that gloria is free to live
if she wishes but if every morning she
remains absent he will take a walk
through the playground not long after
she gets a brilliant idea to stop
oscar's actions
she decides to fly to south korea
upon her arrival she apologizes to tim
for not going with him and also insists
that she does not owe him an explanation
meanwhile oscar gets drunk and walks
into the playground at 8 05 am
as the result the giant robot manifests
in seoul as the city is being evacuated
the people run away from the robot but
not for gloria who is heading towards it
at the same time oscar sees glorious
monsters suddenly appear at the
playground back home
seeing this oscar panics and he
immediately runs away from the monster
in terror luckily gloria manages to
catch him using her hand causing the
robot is being picked up by the non-seen
force
oscar desperately shouts begging the
monster to put him down gloria instantly
makes a throwing gesture followed by the
monster who flings oscar as well as his
giant robot far over the horizon
people in seoul a cheer as the robot is
gone from the city
after everything is done she walks into
an empty bar in seoul while sitting in
her chair she asks the bartender if she
would like to hear an incredible story
however the bartender offers her a drink
instead
at the end she can only sigh about it
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching